Chelsea Clinton is encouraging children
to make a difference in their
communities the bestselling author and
former first daughter has written
several books for kids about current
issues and the empowerment of women her
latest book start now you can make a
difference teaches young people how to
create change Chelsea Clinton is the
vice chair of the Clinton Foundation and
teaches part-time at Columbia University
here in New York good morning good
morning Nora good to see you here it is
I put it on a little post-it on the
front of my book page 106 kindness
creates more kindness yeah I believe
that deeply and I hope that my young
readers put as many sticky notes as you
both did that will be a real mark of
success I do want to talk about so much
in the book but I'd also have to get
your take because we we don't get to
talk to you often about what's happening
in the news we saw the President of the
United States Donald Trump last night
mock dr. Christine Blasi Ford's
testimony in a campaign style rally what
did you make of that not kindness yeah I
hope this isn't an old-fashioned belief
that I don't think the president should
be mocking anyone I don't think you
should be mocking dr. Ford I don't think
he should be mocking a gold star family
I don't think he should be mocking a
disabled reporter mm-hmm I just don't
think that is behavior becoming of our
president what did you think during the
Brett Kavanaugh hearings I was dying to
know when we were sitting there and we
were all there covering it and the
Clinton name came up in his opening
statement did you call your mom or your
dad and say can you believe he just
mentioned our name you all must have had
a discussion about it what was that like
well I didn't watch it live because I
was actually at an event at Yale that
you heard about oh I watched it when I
got home yeah and I just thought oh my
gosh we loomed so much larger in your
mind then you loom at least in mind yeah
like I don't think I'd heard his name
until he was nominated weeks ago but to
me what was so troubling was how nakedly
partisan he was and I think the
principle of judicial review being
absent of partisanship is still really
important so if he had gone after
President Bush or President Reagan's
family I feel
the same way like I just don't think
that that is healthy as a dynamic on the
Supreme Court are really candidly any
court yeah well your mom said the
performance of behavior was quite out of
bounds
and clearly she had some issue was
issues with it do you think that he
should be confirmed to the Supreme Court
I don't
I mean I've opposed his nomination from
the beginning because I don't agree with
his stance on multiple issues and worry
about issues that I really care about
whether it's workers rights or women's
rights or protecting the environment in
many things that the court is expected
to rule on in the future so admittedly
my opposition to him is rooted in policy
but I now AM even more kind of in
intense in my feelings because of how
political he's becoming Chelsea one of
the things that you've really promoted
is reaching out to politicians that
people should start young and reach out
to their local politicians especially
and I'm wondering what your response is
to how we've seen dr. Ford's plight
after she did just that she reached out
to her local congressman said that it
was her civic duty wanted to be
anonymous didn't want to come
public the way she has now and then we
see the result what what is your
response to those who might say you know
what I was going to do that but I don't
need to go through that well I would say
I understand that and I hope you're
still willing to raise your hand raise
your voice
I think we need more people engaged in
the political process at every level not
fewer so wow I completely see beyond
that it could have a chilling effect I
hope that it doesn't what about public
service more broadly I mean you talk
about kindness which is of course
fundamental to the human experience and
yet if you look at our well right I mean
at least fundamental to human happiness
and but we see our public life get more
corrosive more vinegar ish how do you
teach kids oh no it's okay if you
believe in this thing you'll get past
that well I think we teach kids by role
modeling other behavior and by also
calling out what we think is wrong and I
think we also teach kids by elevating
stories of kids who are role modeling
kindness and that's part of what I try
to do and start now I mean one story
that I didn't know
when I was researching the book is the
phenomenon of Buddy benches and I think
about this now every day as a kind of
physical manifestation of kindness but
also a metaphor this young boy Christian
he thought his family was moving to
Germany they went to visit a school
there he saw a buddy bench they wound up
not moving but when he went back to his
school here in the States he said you
know could we have one of those and
thankfully the school supported him and
their four kids to go and sit on if
they're feeling lonely and other kids
are supposed to respect that and kind of
sit down and just talk about their day
talk about how they're doing and now we
have Buddy benches and hundreds of
schools and every single state across
America and you're encouraging kids to
get involved early even though you can't
vote and you can't participate in the
political process there's a great serie
of you at five that you wrote a
political letter to who and about what
so I wrote to President Reagan when I
was five because I had heard that he was
going to visit a cemetery when he
actually visit with my rainbow heart
stickers like Esther of good writing oh
well thank you so I you know I I didn't
think an American president should be
paying his respects to fallen German
soldiers that included Nazis and so I
wrote him this letter saying I'd seen
the sound of music I knew they weren't
nice people I hope if he wouldn't go to
the cemetery he still did go to the
cemetery I never got a response but I
think the optimistic into the story is
when we were moving to Washington my
parents like what do you hope to have
out of this experience and I said I
think every child should get a response
every child that writes the president
should get a response and so my parents
set up the first White House
Correspondents unit just for children
and President Bush continued that
President Obama continued that I have no
idea if President Trump has continued
that but I hope so
in this era of bullying something that
you endured in the public spotlight as
the first daughter what is your advice
to parents who are concerned that their
child may to be bullied in this era of
social media which you didn't really
have so much of going on and you talked
about bullying in the book I do and I
talk about bullying in the book because
it's something I've heard just
consistently from from kids I mean even
more so than from parents and teachers
when I would talk to kids about what's
your mind invariably viana they would
say bullying like how do i stand up to
bullies how do i help protect my friends
and so i just felt like i can't write a
book we're gonna 6 7 8 9 year olds and
not tackle this subject and thankfully
we do know a lot about kind of how kids
can stand up to bullies and also it's
really important to your question that
parents encourage their children to feel
okay about asking for help when they
need it
asking for help is being brave it's not
a sign of weakness and sometimes you
need to tell a trusted adult that you
need their help to stand up and there's
also a bystander obligation so even if
you're not the bully or the one being
bullied you have a responsibility
absolutely
I like Shep I happen to be at a school
event recently and one of the the
teachers talked about teaching young
people about sexual sexual violence and
that was I don't know if that's you know
that's because of the sign of the times
but that that's now part of the
curriculum and a discussion that
teachers are available to teach them
about that that certain age well we have
a lot of research that it is possible to
have age-appropriate and a sexual health
and reproductive health curriculum
really throughout elementary middle and
high school and I think all of us should
support that because we want our kids to
be able to develop a strong and healthy
sense of self and know how to stand up
for themselves but also to John's point
stand up for others well with all the
chapters is very cool because you end us
start now and you give specific steps on
what the kids can do and you know it's a
kids book when the chapter one is water
weather and why we don't drink our poop
to live by yeah because then kids like
why better
it says the kids favorite work yes yeah
thank you very much okay thank you start
now is available now wherever you like
to buy your books